and finally new rule of Jared Kushner is
going to be in charge of peace in the
Middle East trade with China solving the
opioid epidemic reforming the criminal
justice system and reinventing
government he must speak we're almost
six months into the Trump administration
and we have yet to hear Boy Wonder talk
he doesn't even have to explain what
he's got planned for all these
departments where he's now Charles in
charge
he just has to tell us one thing how
does a 36 year old has never worked in a
job his daddy didn't buy become the
second most powerful man in America
right behind Putin
[Applause]
but I got to tell you the answer the
reason why Jared doesn't speak is he
doesn't have to he's never had to ask
for anything he didn't have the grades
or SAT scores to get into Harvard but
then his father gave Harvard two and a
half million dollars and they suddenly
realized that Jared was Ivy League
material after all one clue your
enrollment may not be entirely
merit-based when your acceptance letter
comes with a receipt you know people who
come from money love to call the people
who don't entitled oh they're dead set
against the underprivileged getting
special consideration because that
disincentivizes self-reliance and it's
not achieving through merit meritocracy
is the last thing they want because if
we had that they would stop winning
that's the other reason Jared doesn't
talk he's a [ __ ] idiot the first
thing he did with his inherited wealth
was buy a newspaper in 2006 you know
just as print media was taking off
[Applause]
then in 2007 he used his father's
fortune to pay the highest price ever
for a New York City building right
before the economy a New York real
estate collapsed the secret to real
estate is buy low sell high forwards and
Jarrod got two of them wrong Jarrod's
the one who told Trump that firing Comey
was a good idea he's the one who thought
he could get away with having a secret
meeting with his lyac the 500-pound
Russian ambassador who everyone knows is
constantly being surveilled this guy is
recorded so much he's up for a Grammy
[Applause]
okay all right I got a laugh out of him
the tragedy of the Trump voter is that
they never learn to stop hating the
underprivileged and start hating the
over privileged the greatest
the greatest con Republicans ever pulled
off was convincing the working class
that it was immigrant dreamers and
single moms on food stamps who are
blocking them from the American Dream
when really it's undeserving Schmucks
like Jared who sucked up all the wealth
in this country and that you know that's
the thing about rich guy affirmative
action it's quiet and invisible but very
toxic like farts from a vegetarian we
have a Treasury secretary now Steve
minuchin also known as what men look
like two strippers
who is a former partner at Goldman Sachs
who got to be a partner at Goldman Sachs
the old-fashioned way his father was a
partner at Goldman Sachs and this will
shock you Steve wants to get rid of the
inheritance tax which would mean half
the members of trumps cabinet would save
their kids a billion and a half dollars
when they die oh rich kids you know they
don't inspire a lot of love just by
looking at him but judging by every
single Republican policy they are our
most precious natural resource and those
policies like taking away your health
care so millionaires can get a tax cut
couldn't happen without you Trump voters
without your help
dumb rich ass clowns like Jared Kushner
won't get any richer and may be
sentenced to a life of being it pains me
to say it slightly less obscenely
wealthy but it's not too late you can
help act now and call the number below
and donate what you can to the RNC
[Applause]
donate what you can to the RNC save the
rich [ __ ] campaign call now at 100
seven eight three seven three [ __ ]
that's one eight hundred three seventy
three F CKS
leave you out because God knows they
will